the trump era is coming to a close not
only with a social media blackout for
donald trump on things such as youtube
and twitter
but also it seems the cold shoulder for
many of those in his cabinet
take mike pompeo who's the u.s secretary
of state was due to be in europe on
wednesday
for some high level meetings including
with the general secretary
of nato he said in a tweet just a few
hours ago that he was really looking
forward to those meetings essentially
his swan song for his counterparts here
in europe
but at the very last minute the plug was
pulled on that trip
why well the u.s state department says
that
pompeo who was a man who didn't
recognize the victory of biden
in the u.s election last year is now the
man who wants to make sure that there is
a smooth transition we're fully
committed to the completion of a smooth
and orderly transition process to be
finalized over the next eight days
as a result we're cancelling all planned
travel this week including the
secretary's trip to europe
it's a very different tale though here
in the eu
with apparently pompeo being persona
non-grata
and the european commission saying that
officials didn't
want to meet him they didn't elaborate
on that but we've also heard from
diplomatic sources
there was a sense of embarrassment
around the idea of pompeo
being in europe given that although he
had condemned the violence of
those crowds who had stormed the capitol
building in washington last week
he hadn't said whether president trump
had been a cause of factor
in that however for the luxembourg
foreign minister
he said that trump had egged them on
trump is a criminal a political
pyromaniac who should be sent to the
criminal court
he's a person who was elected
democratically but who isn't interested
in democracy in the slightest
and it also seems that there were other
reasons to save face and to cancel those
meetings because had meetings gone ahead
with officials
in luxembourg there was a problem that
would have had to have been addressed
and this is the compensation for jewish
families whose artifacts were stolen
during the holocaust in the second world
war a dispute between
washington and luxembourg now for a very
long time
and given that some have suggested that
those who stormed the capitol building
in washington last week
were neo-nazi sympathizers this could
have put pompeo in a bit of a pickle
it seems the trump administration will
come to an end not in a blaze of glory
but in a poof of some very black smoke
you